aoc aoc another another one of the
goddesses in the pantheon
of modern leftism another icon
and quasi-religious figure depending on
who you're talking to
she is opening up about how ever since
the january
6th insurrection she
has been going through therapy she's had
a very difficult time she still has not
recovered
from that trauma after the sixth i
took some time and
it was really ayanna presley when i
explained to her what had happened to me
like the day of because i ran to her
office
and she was like you need to recognize
trauma
and that this is something that you went
through but we're all going through
and um and it's really important to
pause after that
because that's how you process it and
i feel like i learned this the hard way
after my father had passed away when i
was a teenager
so that happened at a young age and i
socked it away
and i i had to live with that for years
so you're doing therapy yeah oh yeah
i i'm doing therapy but also
i've just slowed down i think
the trump administration had a lot of us
especially latino communities
in a very reactive mode
i have no doubt that aoc uh endured
suffering as a child as a teenager when
her father died coincidentally there's
very strange parallels between
my life and hers because we grew up in
the towns right next to each other at
exactly the same time and i also lost a
parent when i was a teenager and it's a
very difficult thing i
i do not in any way minimize
the trauma and suffering of that you
like to think that over time heals all
wounds and
over time you can get over that and go
on move on and live your life
so i hope she can do that i've no doubt
that's a real trauma i don't think that
january 6 was a real trauma for her
because
she lied about it she i'm sorry let me
be more specific she exaggerated it
she you can't say she lied because all
she ever talked about was her feelings
she said i
felt as though i was about to be killed
i felt as though my life was at risk
so sure i guess that's your feelings i
can't i can't
disagree with what you felt subjectively
but she never was at risk of dying she
wasn't even in the capital that day she
was across the street
or rather down the street it was a bit
of a walk away she was in her office
building and no one busted in there was
actually a cop who came in to protect
her
and she's milked this for all it's worth
and she says i'm i'm just in the trauma
i'm so broken i've had to slow down i'm
in the therapy for this i can't
it's hard to process and i get it's
really traumatic
we are exalting weakness and
and brokenness in this leftist culture
we are exalting these things we are
actually trying to find ways to claim
that we
are broken hurt aggrieved
disordered unstable it's
got cachet it's got social currency
if you are really that messed up if
you're really that shaken up and you
can't handle it
you should not be in government you
should not be in political leadership
you can't you got to be tough it's hard
but you got to be tough
you got to move on you got to take chin
up
stiff upper lip and move on no matter
look everybody goes through dramas
everybody goes through suffering
sometimes it's real like
aoc had when she was a teenager
sometimes it's contrived like she
exaggerated in her office building on
january 6th
but whatever it is maybe she maybe she
felt terrible in general i don't know
chin up you got to cut this out we've
got to stop
mutilating ourselves ideologically
philosophically physically we've got to
stop
mutilating ourselves and taking things
that are relatively healthy and making
them weaker and
having social currency for grievance and
all trying to grab grievance and
weakness
we've got to get strong if you're not
going to be strong
you're not going to have a flourishing
country
you're going to be mutilating america
all right now that i've got your
attention ring the bell ring the bell
subscribe
like make sure that you get the
notifications while you're at it by the
way
head off of youtube and go on over to
our podcast apps you know apple podcast
spotify google play wherever you listen
to your podcasts make sure you subscribe
we've heard there's some shenanigans
going on with our subscriptions
and our our shows on those apps so just
just to make sure that there's no
glitches or anything like that head on
over subscribe if you wouldn't mind
leave a five-star review
we'll see you next time